costumes and music are not the only
things making this an unusual German
language lesson as the city of Cologne
goes all out for carnival these
volunteers are trying to help prepare
refugees for the culture shock awaiting
them but I'm sure I do my corner I think
it's a great excuse to just be happy and
forget our worries we're strangers here
but we can join in da da da da is a
great initiative for Refugees it gives
us a chance to learn more about German
culture and that's a big help in
adjusting to life in Cologne and in
Germany aqui en de mission sill and
immersion via singing chunker for five
days we sing dance flirt drink beer and
eat candies ritziest Lucia Carmela this
is essential vocabulary that people who
are not from Cologne have to learn in
order to be prepared for the carnival
days but this kind of a class here is
about more than that more than 130
refugees from around the world are
assembled here besides all the
excitement that comes with carnival
they're addressing serious issues such
as behavior it's a sensitive subject
after the sexual assaults in the city on
New Year's Eve advertisement into all
the men here please listen carefully you
have no claim on anyone and that
includes marriage there's no guarantee
when it's carnival Schmitz launched this
class after the New Year's Eve attacks
respectful behavior around women is now
the central issue in car dimension you
know convent huh ponyo newcomers
especially it's important that we drive
home the message that despite all the
carefree activity here and surely it's
free here than in other parts of the
world it is never without respect that's
can sign about what seemed Iman movin
stuff suspect follies let's see what the
refugees think about it themselves it's
good if me and take part in this kind of
class Jennifer how so you'll see that it
is not okay to grope women just because
people are free to go wherever they want
miss raphelson a solution a mother with
it
Margus a strange and new for many people
some might try and take advantage but
not all migrants and refugees are like
that we know what respect is please
don't think we're all like that for most
people here these do's and don'ts are in
any case second nature this workshop
offers a chance to get an insight into a
particular aspect of German culture as
it takes over the streets of Cologne